si lo que sucedió es lo siguiente un
juez decidió ayer por la tarde que la
expresidenta jeanine áñez sea trasladada
a una clínica privada para ser atendida
de la hipertensión que según sus
familiares le está quejando con fuerza
de estos días sin embargo la
procuraduría general del estado que está
dirigida por un ex abogado del ex
presidente evo morales objetó esta
decisión y el juez terminó cambiando su
decisión y dijo que se quede en la
cárcel de obraje espero que reciba
atención médica de un médico del sistema
público sin embargo esta madrugada de
manera sorpresiva el gobierno de luis
arce que es el que controla el sistema
carcelario en bolivia dispuso su
traslado a la cárcel de miraflores como
tú comentabas al llegar la expresidenta
tuvo un breve contacto con los medios
donde denunció que le dijeron que estaba
siendo trasladada a una clínica y no a
una cárcel durante esta jornada el
gobierno de luis arce ha señalado que
años ha sido trasladada a la cárcel de
miraflores para tener mejores
condiciones de atención de salud
los abogados que conocen cómo son las
cárceles de la paz aseguran que la
cárcel de miraflores es una cárcel de
seguridad
mary y se sabe cómo podría avanzar todo
este proceso cuál podría ser el futuro
inmediato oa corto plazo de años
la situación de agnès es bastante
compleja porque por un lado está acusada
de sedición terrorismo y conspiración en
este caso en la justicia ordinaria por
el que el gobierno ya ha anunciado que
va a pedir 30 años de prisión sin
embargo también el mismo gobierno le ha
planteado otros cuatro juicios pero esta
vez de responsabilidades y que deben
sustanciarse en el congreso y por tanto
la situación de años les decía es
bastante compleja pero debo comentarles
que en las últimas horas la iglesia
católica se ha pronunciado en el sentido
de que las reuniones que la iglesia ha
dirigido durante 2019 para pacificar el
país no ha servido para conspirar en
contra de ningún gobierno pues evo
morales ya había renunciado al poder y
que esas reuniones que son la base de
sustentación de la fiscalía en realidad
lo que se buscó es hacer una sucesión
constitucional y que el movimiento al
socialismo habría estado de acuerdo con
esta situación